- Thank you all for coming
in this dreary weather,
and I really
appreciate it since I
know there's so much going
on all the time around here.
Thank you to my
fellow Radcliffers
for being so generous, and so
smart, and stimulating already.
And I've already learned
so much and look forward
to learning more from.
This fellowship came to me
at a very important moment,
which is probably what
everybody says when
they get any fellowship, right?
But specifically, for me, I
feel like I'm desperately trying
to let go of an old project--
a long term project and move
on to one, or two, or three,
or however many projects I'm
able to accomplish in my time
here.
And it's already beginning
to be an exciting--
I already feel the
energy of that.
So don't be frightened by the
overwhelming amount of images.
It's not just because
I'm a visual artist
that I'm showing
you images, but it's
because images are really
important to my practice
and my way of working.
So if you don't know
any of the names
I'm mentioning, or don't
know what's happening,
or are confused at all,
that's perfectly fine,
and hopefully there's more
to the work than that.
So I'm just going to begin.
So I really had
no idea what I was
doing when I came across this
image back in graduate school,
and I certainly
had no idea that it
would lead me slowly and somehow
circuitously to the place
that I'm at now, but it
remains relevant to what
I'm interested in
still today, I guess
because it's the first
time I was consciously
aware of a shift in my interest
from architecture as building
to architecture as
image, for at the time,
I had been merely,
though lovingly,
making drawings of somewhat
bleak communist inspired
architecture, as
Judy mentioned, that
hearkened back to my six years
in Czechoslovakia as a child.
When this image by the
architect Adolf Loos,
captioned "bedroom for my
wife, or my wife's bedroom"
crossed my path.
There were only two
images of that bedroom
that I found in print of two
slightly different views.
And as far as we all know,
there is no other record
of this space that exists today.
From that image and for
various reasons, including
the architecture
itself, I became,
for a time, absorbed with the
many other images of interiors
by Adolf Loos, and,
as I already said,
I didn't know exactly
why at the time,
but I would later learn
through the writings
of Beatriz Colomina about
how Adolf Loos destroyed much
of his own archive and doctored
the photos of his interiors,
maintaining full control of
how his work was disseminated
in contrast to the
work of Le Corbusier,
for example, who kept
every single thing
and embraced mass
media as a strategy.
The Loos images seemed
enigmatic, doctored, presented,
stage-like, fictional.
And just a small
example of that--
if you notice in this
image, there is a face.
I don't have a
pointer, but if you
look at the little square of the
door, just to the right of it
there's somebody's profile
walking up the stairs.
And whether or not
this was accidental,
or whether he missed
this in taking the photo
and it was just about
movement, I'm not sure,
but these are the funny things
that kind of sometimes came up
within his sort of
very controlled images
of his architecture.
I spent some time
in Vienna, visited
much of his
architecture, and made
some of my own interventions in
the form of drawings and larger
installations.
And from Loos, it
then seemed natural
that I moved my way
through more images
and architectural documents
by all, or at least
a large portion, of the other
modernist architects in Europe,
mostly working post turn of the
century and pre-World War II.
Zigzagging across the continent,
discovering everything
from the likes of the lesser
known Robert Mallet-Stevens,
who, on top of creating
many captivating structures
and buildings, also produced
stage sets for films,
such as this image here.
Images of his seemed to
fuse together consciously
and publicly the stage
in architecture in a way
that Loos did somewhat
accidentally and privately.
Then, staying for a while
in France, for example,
I was impressed by
the technical magic
of Jean Prouve, a collaborator
of Mallet-Stevens.
And again, all
along I was playing
around with my own
reinterpretations
as in this example of a
larger piece exhibited
in London that uses
Prouve's screen
structure as inspiration.
I continued to both physically
and metaphorically move
around from country to country.
I spent some time in the
north in the Netherlands
with the compelling, broad
range, socially engaged,
yet somehow aesthetically
rigidly defined
work of JJP Oud and the better
known De Stijl heroes, Theo van
Doesburg and Gerrit Rietveld,
all the while being drawn
into images such as
this one, a house by Oud
and a floor by Doesburg.
I particularly love
it when questions
arise when looking at
images of interiors
like, what is that floor doing?
Is this even a real space?
It seemed funny to
me that something
so practical and solid
such as architecture
would be represented
by something
so fuzzy and uncertain.
Again, finding ways to
make something of my own
in response to their work, I
was learning about architecture
through redrawing, collaging,
making installations,
and expanding the framework
of the images I was seeing,
trying to find my own way
into a space, some space,
perhaps the space
of the image itself.
And maybe, though it
might be a stretch,
I was unconsciously practicing
in a subtle form of mimicry--
or not so subtle at times--
all the while getting over
ever closer to Eastern Europe,
as is visually obvious
from this work, where
it seems like I
had my own brief,
but intense relationship with
the Russian constructivists.
Quite embarrassingly
so, I would say.
And as I was sifting through
the doctrines and the dogmas,
it became clear that it was the
documentation of architecture
that was more and more
interesting to me.
Just as I would later read
in the Colomina texts,
it was the correspondence,
the travel, the connections,
the pamphlets, and the
image, as Colomina posits,
where the true site of
modernity takes place
and where the private
becomes public.
It was, for me, about what
lies just outside of the image
and beyond the frame, and
therefore, slowly, in a way,
biography secretly
became my subject matter.
It was, at least still
a secret to me then.
Throughout my research,
I was no doubt quite
taken with the work and life of
Charlotte Perriand and Eileen
Gray.
Working diligently alongside
their male colleagues,
they were extremely
innovative, adventurous,
and working against all odds
while somehow never conforming
to the normative, both
in lifestyle and design.
This is an early Charlotte
Perriand bar designed in 1927,
and this is the guestroom
in Eileen Gray's
now legendary and
almost mythical
seeming E-1027 House on the
coast of south of France
where so much happened that
it almost seems unbelievable.
As some of you might
know, there was
a whole lot of confusion about
who actually made the house.
Was it Corbusier?
And also Corbusier
was painting paintings
while being naked on
her walls, and so there
was all this great stuff that
happened there that almost
seems like it's not real.
If you don't know about
it, I can tell you
more about it later.
And so the stories
are complicated.
The lines are often blurred.
Who made what?
Were they a couple?
Did one steal something
from the other?
There is still most
likely much that
is unknown about the practices
of architects and designers,
about their collaborations
and their achievements.
There's Lilly Reich
with Mies van der Rohe,
Charlotte Perriand with Le
Corbusier, Walter and Ise
Gropius, Stepanova
with Rodchenko,
Nelly Doesburg with
husband Theo van Doesburg--
all of the fierce, stylish
Bauhaus woman ahead
of their time.
And I don't want to undermine
their already obscure
achievements, but it's
just true that they really
did have the best hairstyles.
[LAUGHTER]
There's no denying it.
And after all of this,
I guess one can call it
some form of research.
The file boxes and
binders in my studio,
in addition to obviously
also being named
by the names
themselves, then read
with headings and subheadings
the Austrian architects,
the French architects,
the Hungarian architects,
the men working.
There's quite a lot
of those, obviously.
For every image,
there's like 1,000
more that I didn't
include, obviously.
Men looking at their models is
a whole subcategory that I love.
The man with woman.
The woman with groups of men.
There's some of those.
The woman looking
out of the windows
of various architectural
spaces designed by men
with their backs turned to us.
That's a large category.
The woman reading in
various architectural spaces
designed by men.
And in case you were
beginning to get worried,
there are even a few
pictures of women working.
And eventually, by far the
greatest number of files
became dedicated to the
regional and lesser known area
of modernism in Eastern
Europe, including, of course,
the work of designer
and architect
Petra Andrejova-Molnar.
I will briefly read to you a
section of Molnar's biography
as it was written in the first
catalog that was published
on the occasion of an
exhibit called Between Brno
and Budapest in Cologne.
During the inter-war
period, young architects
such as Joseph Fischer,
Bohuslav Fuchs, Jaromir Krejcar,
and Petra Andrejova-Molnar,
to name a few,
were at the center of a
vibrant architectural community
in the newly
established Czechoslovak
and Hungarian People's Republic.
Born between 1895 and
1901, they came of age
with the countries
that rose from
the Austro-Hungarian empire's
demise in October, 1918.
In the shifting political
arena of redrawn boundaries,
these architects were
emboldened by the utopian spirit
of the age and embrace
an architecture that
championed modernity,
efficiency, functionality,
and a commitment to human
progress and innovation.
While dedicated to
architecture's role
in the politically
reorganized region,
these architects
were international
in their sophisticated
aesthetic approach.
Publications such as
[INAUDIBLE] and Devetsil
were instrumental in
publicizing developments
from Western Europe
and the United States.
While CIAM and the periodicals
provided a connection
to international
developments and architects
in France, the
Netherlands, and Germany,
the demands of a local
clientele and the desire
of the Czechoslovak and
Hungarian CIAM members
impressed a unique
quality on their projects.
Reinforced concrete
architectural skeletons,
for example, were
frequently combined
with dramatic terraces
along the hillsides
and coasts of the region.
The tendency to
linear efficiency
and an aesthetic
emphasis on load bearing
and otherwise functional
building components
was applied to smaller
single family homes,
rather than to elaborate
villas for the wealthy,
thus concentrating
on functional housing
through which to build a
better world in the new Europe.
This forward looking approach
was central to several seminal
exhibitions, beginning with
the first housing exhibit
at the newly formed Czechoslovak
[NON-ENGLISH] in Brno in 1928.
The location, Brno, known where
both Fuchs and Molnar spent
extended periods in the
1920s, was rapidly becoming
a center for architectural
investigation
and had begun to attract
international attention.
Mies van der Rohe built the
famous Tugendhat House there
in 1929 and '30.
Such was the fertile environment
in Petra Andrejova-Molnar's
design ambitions were nurtured.
PA, as she later came to
be professionally known,
was born Petra Josefina
Andrejova in [NON-ENGLISH],,
Moravian Czechoslovakia in 1898.
She studied at Vienna's
Academy of Fine Arts
and traveled extensively in the
early 1920s, spending periods
of time in Brno, Budapest,
Prague, Vienna, and Berlin.
It was in these years
that she encountered
the Hungarian architect
Farkas Molnar, who
would later become her husband
and sometimes collaborator.
PA's work comprised of
many drawings, models,
and unrealised projects for
Czechoslovak [NON-ENGLISH]
exhibits.
Her contributions, such
as Modern Apartment,
Brno, 1927, are principally
small scale housing designs
that reflect the contemporary
European interest
in ideal dwellings and
efficient spatial organization.
While PA's
architecture is steeped
in contemporary
developments, she
would have been aware of earlier
Czech architects, such as Jan
Kotera, the one time
Otto Wagner protege, who
both brought secessionist
inspired design to Prague
and advocated a
specifically Czech style.
As a student in
Vienna, PA would have
been exposed to
the Austrian work
of her Moravian predecessors,
Josef Hoffmann and Adolf Loos.
While her aesthetics
would seem to be divorced
from these earlier
architects, she subtly
drew from their
approach to materials--
for example, in the shade
wall of her Hotel Nord-Sud
or in the storefront
designs of 193-39,
which hold Adolf Loos and
the Austrian style in mind.
By the second half
of the 1920s, PA
had begun to gain practical
architectural experience.
Despite her youth and the
dearth of opportunities offered
to her gender, she
secured positions
in some of the
region's most prominent
architectural offices.
From 1927-29, she worked
with both Bohuslav Fuchs
on his Avion Hotel,
which in its simplicity
and open economically
stacked spaces
informed her future
hotel designs.
She furthered her
training in the design
of public buildings
in 1928-30 when
she worked with the
architect the Jaromir
Krecjar on his Machnac
Sanitorium in Trencianske
Teplice.
Krecjar's functionalist
approach to design
would be a strong influence
on PA's later work,
and his attention to symmetry
and emphasis on terraces
would inform PA's designs.
In 1932, PA embarked upon
what was to become undoubtedly
her signature inter-war work,
the remarkable Hotel Nord-Sud.
Unfortunately abandoned after
the war and later destroyed,
the hotel was located on
the coast of Yugoslavia
near the town of Zadar.
Both Molnar and Fuchs gave the
project their full support,
but the triumph of this
understated masterwork
is PA's alone.
This small hotel, her first
large scale construction,
contained 14 cabin-like
bedrooms and two suites,
all with balconies, as well
as an impressive lookout
cafe on the third floor, and
an open restaurant and bar
on the second.
The Hotel Nord-Sud's most
arresting design elements
were surely the
remarkable terraces
that united interior to exterior
with only the separation
of glass.
The hotel's ground floor
boasted four meter high ceilings
in a flexible, open reception
and, again here, extensive use
of glass that allowed the
constant sight of the sea
through the structure's
floating, transparent supports.
Finally, the cantilevered roof,
nautical and yet restrained,
was balanced by symmetrical
modular interior spaces.
The Hotel Nord-Sud
was the culmination
of Molnar's formative
years and, in many ways,
synthesizes the architecture
trends of the time.
It is a structure that defines
an era that is now lost to us,
like the building itself.
Architecture in Central
and Eastern Europe
was no longer able to embrace
hopeful internationalism
and youthful idealism,
and though PA and many
of her contemporaries continued
to practice architecture
after a hiatus
occasioned by the war,
they did so in a
world vastly altered
from the inter-war years
between Brno and Budapest.
This is a second
publication dedicated
to Molnar's work, recently
published in 2016,
from which I'll read a short
section of a beautiful essay
by architectural
historian Sean Keller.
"Against all of this,
one might object.
What about those male
heroes of heroic modernism?
Yet how real were they
with their invented names--
Le Corbusier, van der Rohe--
and their costumes-- the
cape, the glasses, the cigar--
and costume parties, with
their doctored photographs,
pasted up collages,
and canvas mockups,
cutting and gluing their
past, present, and future
into the shapes they desired.
Their little self-important,
self published journals
written by themselves, perhaps
under multiple pseudonyms
and a few friends, and all of
those buildings, even cities
for one million, designed
for people, and technologies,
and opinions that
didn't yet exist."
"For what was modern
architecture if not
the summoning up of a new world,
new ways of living, seeing,
and building?
This world had to be
projected before it
could be legislated and built,
projected through drawing,
model making,
photography, and writing.
The incredible magical
fact is the extent
to which this summoning worked.
Those odd journals, grainy
photos, and miniature buildings
did, somehow, remake the world.
And what, too,
about the myth that
says that the architect
makes architecture?
Isn't the architect really
more like an organizing force,
perhaps even an imaginary one,
wrapping around or running
through a flow of people,
materials, images, money,
space, and time, trying
to cajole and compel
all of the hands that sign
contracts, write checks, draw
details, dig holes, lay bricks,
paint walls, manufacture lamps,
take photographs,
and write reviews
to construct something they
may never have seen before?"
"Yet, like some myths, the
story of the architect making
architecture is both literally
untrue and still not false,
for there is, or may be,
a singular sensibility
and intelligence
guiding the production,
but given the complexity of
realizing any project, who
could say where the
architect stopped or started?
Or if, perhaps, he or she
were ever there at all?"
I had asked Sean
Keller to contribute
to the catalog of Molnar's
work, and since he
is a legitimate
historian of architecture
at Illinois Institute
of Technology,
he felt uncomfortable talking
about PA as if she was real.
And by now I'm assuming everyone
here knows that she's not--
or you knew that already--
but without even
mentioning Molnar's name,
he beautifully
captured the essence
and put his finger on some
of the ideas and issues that
have become important to me
throughout creating Molnar's
archive over the years.
These last few images were
of several exhibitions
that have taken
place-- for example,
the exhibition in Cologne,
Between Brno and Budapest.
In each new exhibition
iteration of her work,
a different context
is developed.
New work is added, and a
slightly longer or different
story is told.
Models are made that recreate
fictional and actual buildings,
built and unbuilt. For example,
in this case, Farkas Molnar's
red cube house project, which
garnered attention, but was
never realized during his
short time in the Bauhaus.
In this exhibition, the
biographies as wall text
become an equally
important means by which
authority is put into question.
Sometimes the realness
of actual biographies
becomes a little suspicious.
Hotel Nord-Sud 1932-34
design and correspondence
took place at the
ICA, foregrounding
the influence of sanatorium
design on PA's Hotel Nord-Sud.
The exhibition focused
on a closer look
at Nord-Sud Hotel's interior.
The lobby furniture,
such as wall sconces,
and light fixtures,
and hotel signage
was all particularly situated
within PA's design language.
The wall text stated that,
while much of this furniture
claimed to be lost
or destroyed, it
was reproduced according to
the drawings and documents that
remained.
The writing desk, vanity
chair, and bed with night table
all reiterate the stylistic
proportions and horizontal
cantilever design of the hotel.
Some installation images
from the exhibition.
At the Kunstverein
Langenhagen in Hanover,
the work focused on the
collaborative efforts of PA
and the ways in which the
many historical publications
functioned to distribute
and disseminate ideas
across continents.
There are certain
objects and interests
that run throughout PA's
career, like for example,
her interest in the screen
structure as a dividing element
throughout interiors
and exteriors.
Many of these were
unrealized, but she
seemed to have a particular
investment in their development
nevertheless.
In the last iteration,
an exhibition
focused on PA's earliest
collaborative project,
before her career had really
begun, designed by Josef Gocar,
the Czechoslovakian pavilion
at the 1925 International
Exposition of Modern Industrial
and Decorative Arts in Paris--
that's a long sentence--
bridged traditional designs
and an avant garde aesthetic.
While the pavilion's
exterior was
inspired by abstracted
nautical forms,
its interior rooms combined
self-conscious references
to folk art and the Renaissance,
alongside geometric cubism.
Working under Gocar and Janak,
the exhibition wall text
states that PA was assigned to
many aspects of the pavilion
design, and although precise
records of her involvement
have not survived, her
characteristic desire
for efficient
simplicity of form can
be seen in a number of
the pavilion elements.
Perhaps her greatest
known contribution
was the terra cotta
brise sole which
projected from either
side of the building.
And here you can see in the
exhibition the terra cotta wall
reconstruction.
In addition, PA was
largely entrusted
with the design and
tapestry work for two
of the pavilion's interiors--
the Room for a Modern
Man and its companion,
Room for a Modern Woman,
which featured furniture
by Jan Kotera.
Despite references to
Czechoslovakian folk art,
PA's designs remain
abstract, and their geometry
compliments Kotera's interest
in space and construction
and his move away from
form and decoration.
PA's hand can also be seen in
smaller, but important elements
of the exhibition design,
such as the small shelves,
mirrors, and wall
sconces she conceived
for the two idealized
modern rooms.
And finally in the
pedestals on which
Czech ceramics by Vlastislav
Hofmann, Paval Janak,
and others were displayed.
Here, too, PA presented
simplified geometries,
pared down forms which echo
the ceramics' angular planes.
The project of creating
a fictional character
was not at all a well
thought out decision for me.
I had not set out or
planned to create her.
It occurred organically
because of several interests.
At first, because of my love
of architectural drawings
and the potential that
I saw in them to convey
latent content veiled beneath
the seemingly pragmatic,
as well, of course, because
of my love of making objects.
Then because of my interest
in the dissemination
of architectural
image, as I tried
to describe earlier, as well
as an interest in the ideology
and discourse coming out of
utopian modernist thinkers,
and consequently the
following failure of that very
same thing.
And, of course, an interest
in how the biographical plays
a role in our ability to connect
to and understand the past.
It was probably,
also, a personal
attempt to interject myself
into a location and time
that I felt originally
I had come from,
but was disconnected with.
And last but not
least, the project
became a way to
insert what I thought
was missing from one version
of modernist history.
So how to follow a very
long fictional project,
and will I ever get out of it?
Born Francesca Porges in
Vienna, my current subject
immigrated to the US in
1938, attended Smith College,
and in 1944 obtained her
master's degree from Harvard's
Graduate School of Design.
After running her own furniture
design company, Hosken Inc.,
for a decade, Hosken became an
activist for women's health.
Her archives here at the
GSD, the Schlessinger,
and elsewhere tell the vivid
story of an underexamined life.
I came upon the four boxes at
the Graduate School of Design
by accident when I first
arrived at Harvard,
and I instantly
became fascinated.
The archival photographs
of her furniture
and of herself posing
with her creations
were immediately intriguing.
They seemed to provide
the real for the fictional
that I was already
so steeped in.
The images, documents,
and story that
was unfolding within
Fran Hosken's archives
mirror the story I was trying
to tell through Molnar.
The archives of the
GSD consists mostly
of photographs of Hosken's work,
rather than the work itself.
Except for some of the
jewelry she designed,
it mostly consists
of a large number
of images of her
furniture, staged
and used for advertising
the work for clients.
There are approximately
45 unique works
of design documented
in the archive.
Several versions of slightly
different serving carts.
MDF trays and magazine racks all
made out of simple materials,
easily produced, and
made to be affordable.
There's pamphlets and financial
documents from the company,
drawings, jewelry,
correspondence, et cetera.
So from a first
look at the archive,
it appears to be a fairly
successful business
and design career,
except, of course,
it wasn't, as you can see in
this letter from 1974, which
was received after Hosken,
already engaged in a long back
and forth complaint battle
with Harvard and the GSD
for having
nontransparent, dubious,
and non-diverse
hiring strategies.
Take a minute to read it.
Sorry.
It just didn't cut it.
The context Hosken
was working in
is also evident in the various
compelling correspondence
with some of the major
architects in the area.
Walter Gropius, Philip
Johnson, Saarinen, Tack,
and a few others.
In the above letter,
Hosken is asking
Gropius to help her sell
Hosken Inc. because it is
no longer financially viable.
It's a long letter, but that's
basically what happens in it.
In this back and
forth, for example,
with Philip Johnson, which you
can see in the gallery space--
I believe it's there.
Phillip Johnson is interested
only in Hosken's legs,
without the table tops, to
offer some of his clients--
a very sort of strange
attempt that actually
resulted in failure, as well.
"Yes, dear Francesca, I am
much impressed with your table
legs."
That goes on for a little bit.
So it's clear that
Hosken decided
to turn her life into solely
a feminist and activist cause.
She did, in fact, within
that field, accomplish much,
and it's not that the endeavor
isn't fully respectable--
and most likely, even more so--
but it's hard to try to
understand how much failure
and rejection one needs to be
met with before they throw away
a career ambition
or life passion.
Is that even an interesting
or relevant question to ask?
My first instinct was to exhibit
Hosken's work, accompanying it
with the first
comprehensive catalog.
My methods are thoroughly
interdisciplinary,
first beginning
with research, which
I've obviously just begun.
Furniture needs to be
tracked down or remade.
How much biography
will be included?
Questions about the
innovation of her design
and justifications for the
failures and shortcomings
will surely arise.
Does any part of
the activist work
inform the reading
of her practice
as a designer in any way?
Will this research even
result in anything regarding
the design work
at all, or will it
rather become more immersed
with the topic of the obstacles
surrounding her?
Since, of course, I am an
artist and obviously not
a historian or a scholar, it's
in the studio where research
is thought through, where forms
for the exhibition catalog
and who knows what
else get invented.
The project will be hands on,
subjective, and speculative,
but also will hopefully harness
modes of scholarly writing.
There is much that happens
in contemporary art out
of research, but I am
interested in a more
nuanced and multidirectional
approach, producing
some of the scholarship
from which I draw.
It isn't surprising
that many artists who
are interested in the
archive as a subject matter
are in some way drawn to the
misplaced, the incomplete,
the unfulfilled, and often look
for something in the archive
to offer a point of departure.
And finally, I'll conclude
my talk by adding that,
in order to help move the
research of Fran Hosken
into new territory
hopefully, I want
to bring up a blip of
an unfinished project
from earlier this year, which
I hope can act as a guide
to a non-linear
research strategy.
I'll try to tell the story
as quickly as possible.
I was invited to do a
workshop and exhibition
for the inauguration
of a recently restored
beautiful Peter Behren
synagogue in a town located
40 minutes away from my parents
origins in rural Slovakia.
I wrote up a fancy agenda
and syllabus for the workshop
and invited local
students to participate.
We were supposed to
create models of aspects
or recollections of our past--
or someone's past-- much in
the same way I was already
trying to do at the time,
which I consider also
an unfinished project that
lacks the proper form still,
but my attempt was
to construct models
of the memories of my
parents' time in a refugee
camp in Yugoslavia while
waiting for papers to immigrate
to Canada.
I had realized that no
photos from that time exist,
though we have plenty from
before and right after,
and so new aspects of the
story kept coming up every time
I asked something--
things I had not heard from my
parents about this time before.
Like this cabin,
for example, which
I had no idea we spent time
in, was given to us by the UN,
and somehow I so
desperately wanted
to know what it looked like,
even though it was probably
a banal camping cabin.
So I tried to create it based
on their messy and confused
descriptions.
Trying to remember
specifics and materials
became an interesting
process of back and forth
and brought up all kinds
of new revelations.
And there is this model of the
US embassy entrance in Zagreb
that my mother tried
to recall, but all she
remembered was hurriedly walking
down some terrazzo stairs
while hearing
footsteps behind her,
paranoiacally thinking
she's being followed,
and ignoring her family outside
so they wouldn't get caught.
So back to the
synagogue, the students
were supposed to be
thinking about architecture
as a witness, the theme
of my fancy workshop,
but without getting into
the details, in many ways,
the entire workshop
was a failure.
We had nothing to show for our
three intense days of meeting,
and somehow something
of a piece had
to be left in the space of
the synagogue for the opening.
I tried every
avenue and ended up
with this minimal
footprint of a piece that
told the story of me
trying to make the piece
and linking it to
every other thing
I was thinking
about at the time.
What resulted were five
simple fake plaques
that told some aspect of
how different events related
to the space of the synagogue,
even if in less obvious ways.
This particular plaque
commemorated a small moment
of the workshop, and those are
all the participants' names,
and we read a passage
from a Sebald book.
My uncle had a very personal
relationship to the synagogue,
as his family is from
that town, and he
told me a very interesting
story that I was not
allowed to share with anyone.
And so I made a plaque for that.
So it reads this
synagogue is known
to him because of his eight
years of study at the gymnasium
in [INAUDIBLE].
He used pass it on his
way to and from school.
He told me a very
interesting story
about the house with three
apartments that his parents
built in [INAUDIBLE] in 1931.
A few hours later, he asked
me not to share the story,
so I'm honoring his wishes.
And I wove the UN cabin
back into the story,
as well, because that same uncle
sponsored our move to Canada.
And lastly, this
is a commemoration
to the important
conversations that
were exchanged during that time
that might lead to something
exciting in the
future, for it's always
really hard to put an object
to these types of exchanges.
These seemingly
disparate plaques
attempt to tell a story
in a non-linear way that
incorporates or
keeps the presence
of the building as an integral
component of experience
and memory.
It is a tiny
project that is more
like a clause within
a sentence still,
but I hope that my
work with Fran Hosken
will be somehow
informed by this,
and that perhaps her
life and her work
will ultimately function
as a point of departure.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]